Johnny Depp joins the cast of fantastic
beasts while his daughter lily-rose
celebrates her very first Vogue cover it
was amazing it's a great week for the
Depp clan et can confirm the 53 year old
actor will appear in the sequel to
fantastic beasts and where to find them
although little is known about his
character we're told he will have a
cameo in the first film which hits
theatres November 18th welcome to New
York
meanwhile Depp's seventeen-year-old
daughter lily-rose scored a major
modeling milestone appearing on the
december cover of British Vogue there's
nothing basic here Lily Rose shared the
stunning cover shot to Instagram
Saturday and gushed in the caption
quotes such a dream come true
she's very flattering she's doing a
great job she's killing it inside the
mag the brunette beauty got candid about
growing up in the spotlight with famous
parents she explained quote my parents
weren't very strict they've always
trusted me to be independent and make my
own decisions there wasn't really
anything to rebel against
you